de Berlin avec vous Anne-Marie vous êtes
sur place pour France 24
Anne l'Allemagne a pris un virage à 180
degrés le plus grand virage de son
histoire on n'imaginait pas il y a un an
encore que ce pays pourrait livrer des
armes et pourtant on est en bonne voie
oui c'est vrai que le 24 février 2022 a
marqué pour l'Allemagne une véritable
césure il a renversé de nombreuses
certitudes et bouleversées la doctrine
allemande en matière de défense de
diplomatie de commerce également alors
il faut se souvenir quand même qu'avant
l'invasion massive de l'Ukraine par la
Russie l'Allemagne était extrêmement
dépendante des hydrocarbures et
notamment du gaz russe les gazeux ducs
stream 2 en été la parfaite illustration
et pendant des décennies Berlin pensait
même que ces échanges commerciaux avec
Moscou pouvaient contribuer au
développement de la démocratie en Russie
alors tout cela évidemment a
complètement volé en éclat le 24 février
2022 et depuis et bien Berlin c'est
sevré très largement de sa dépendance
aux hydrocarbures l'Allemagne a
également rompu avec sa tradition
pacifiste puisque le gouvernement a
débloqué notamment à fond spécial de 100
milliards d'euros pour son armée et le
gouvernement livre également des armes
toujours plus puissantes à l'Ukraine
alors que l'Allemagne avait pour
principe de ne pas fournir d'armes à des
pays en guerre donc c'est véritablement
un changement d'époque pour reprendre le
terme employé par le chancelier allemand
ou la
de l'opinion publique allemande qu'elle
regarde elle porte sur ses 365 jours de
guerre écoulée du soutien de l'Allemagne
et bien les Allemands restent très
tiraillés entre d'un côté leur volonté
de soutenir l'Ukraine d'afficher leur
solidarité et puis de l'autre leurs
craintes d'être entraîné dans cette
guerre alors les sondages évidemment
varient beaucoup mais une étude montre
que 48% des Allemands sont toujours
favorables au livraison d'armes il était
55% en avril 2022 et surtout une large
majorité d'entre eux pensent que le
gouvernement n'est pas assez ne fait pas
assez d'efforts diplomatiques pour
mettre fin à cette guerre donc on sent
ici un léger effritement lié aussi
certainement aux difficultés économiques
rencontrées par les Allemands depuis un
an avec une inflation record le prix de
l'énergie qui a beaucoup augmenté et
puis comme je vous le disais aussi il y
a cette crainte très forte que le
soutien grandissant de l'Allemagne à
l'Ukraine soit perçue comme une
provocation par Vladimir Poutine
d'ailleurs un manifeste qui demande
l'arrêt des livraisons d'armes à
l'Ukraine pour éviter
une escalade nucléaire du conflit à
recueilli plus de 600 000 signatures ces
derniers jours en Allemagne il a été
lancé par une députée de la gauche
radicale divine et une grande figure du
féminisme allemand alors ce texte est
très critiqué en Allemagne car il
explique en gros que la Russie ne pourra
jamais être vaincu par l'Ukraine et que
les livraisons d'armes ne font
qu'aggraver la situation mais ces
auteurs appellent à manifester demain à
Berlin et espère réunir 10000 personnes
merci beaucoup à notre maillet en direct
depuis